Western Rio de Janeiro in Islam were
fights between gangs and the police
happen almost every day these men are
part of the third command a drug
trafficking group formed in the 1990s
in recent years the members have
expanded its area of influence to other
countries
we move in Paraguay and Bolivia areas
close to the border and from there we
get the drugs the guns and all of this
the third command is an offshoot of one
of Brazil's most powerful drug
trafficking organizations the Commando
vermelo or red command they say they're
facing new challenges now
the government of bolsonaro made it
easier for people to get weapons it
makes it more challenging for us because
now getting weapons and ammunition is
more expensive sometimes more difficult
but we find the way around it we always
do
they claim to be an army of 120 people
ready to fight the police and rival
gangs we saw them but we're not allowed
to film all of them this area is
controlled by the third command drug
trafficking organizations and Everywhere
You Look they're young men carrying
machine guns an example of how these
groups recruit their soldiers violence
and crime is a priority for many people
in this election and both presidential
candidates are promising to fight it
but fighting them is a challenge and
comes at an expense
Patricia costasan Douglas was killed
during a police operation this year near
her home in the Villa Crusade of Favela
in Rio more than 20 others were killed
during the raid in May
cortas blames president for her son's
death
I never expected this I got a call and I
had to go to the morgue and I saw he was
tortured he was shot three times my son
was a hard worker a good son he was
everything to me but the police killed
him and since bolsonaro came to power
there is more violence here
most of the victims of police raids are
generally black and poor
human rights groups have denounced the
increase of violent police tactics since
yair volsonaro took office
is a strong supporter of the use of
force to battle crime last year more
than 6 000 people were killed by the
police according to the Brazilian Forum
on Public Safety
annalize whomever wins the presidency
will have to find a new approach
we're talking about criminal gangs that
have a strong presence in Latin America
and Europe and that are a prisons also
in small cities across Brazil the most
violent cities in Brazil are now in the
Amazon in the Northeast and follow the
road of cocaine the structure of
organizations has changed and the
strategy has to change
gangs say they're used to fighting the
police and they will continue to do so
no matter who wins Sunday's vote
but people like Patricia korta are
demanding change so that what occurred
to her family won't happen again
Rio De Janeiro Brazil